[Applause]
[Music]
give me one minute and I'll show you how
Google kubernetes engine can help you
modernize your existing application gke
is an enterprise-grade platform for
stateful and stateless containerized
apps
it offers managed kubernetes and is
comprised of a high availability control
plane that Google manages and operates
nodes which hold the pods and you're
connected Google cloud services you can
interact with it using cube CDL or the
cloud console G K increases developer
productivity with pre-built deployment
templates featuring Portability and
integrated tools to accelerate app
development and deployment cycles it
simplifies platform operations with Auto
scale auto upgrade and auto repair
features it is secured by default
including data encryption and
vulnerability scanning of container
images and it supports integrated cloud
monitoring with infrastructure
application and kubernetes specific
beads gke can help modernize your
applications create a continuous
delivery pipeline or migrate your
existing two-tier app next time you're
thinking about modernizing your apps
quickly take a minute to look at google
kubernetes engine for more info check
out cloud.google.com slash kubernetes
engine